e aí galera que assistiu ao canal todo
bom vocês é a galera de mato grosso do
sul que eu vou ter um final de semana e
só pra vocês dia 30 de outubro está em
dourados no teatro municipal e no dia 1º
de novembro voltará em campo grande no
teatro glauce rocha
o ingresso índice é só entrar nesse site
está aparecendo aqui ó toque na tela até
para comprar pela internet e transporte
devendo esse dia me reunir com o pessoal
da família aí quem sabe sempre que o
pessoal da família hora da foto em que
hora da foto é bom que tenham raiva
noite tirar foto é que sei que a gente
vai tirar foto a pessoa que vai tirar
foto até uma senha no celular é parece
que na hora da foto a ser triplicado
tarde no meio ea pessoa buga antiga
assim vão tirar foto faz a posição não
deixa o celular no ponto de tirar foto
não espera todo mundo fazer a pose se
abraçar sempre tem um primo que não tem
intimidade fazer uns quatro anos quero
ver então é um amigo do seu primo que
você não conhece você sai do lado dele
se abraça a pessoa fica assim beleza
beleza vamos lá a pessoa é botar aqui
para roubar a câmera ea gente aqui
abraçar o estranho beleza na vontade
popular bebida e bota na câmara que ram
e aí na escola família boa marca taeq
asseca aí começa a bater um álbum
despertar abraçar com estranho e beleza
pessoa consegue desbloquear o céu a
pronta e tá na cama eu vou tirar foto
agora em só que hoje em dia celular
nenhum mais tem tecla tudo na tela e
sempre a pessoa que ela vai bater a foto
ela confunde o botão de tirar foto com
button vai continuar vamos lá vão tirar
foto vai dar o chez todo mundo lá vai
assistirei da câmera a como eu sou
porque você lavar saco estranho meu deus
acaba qualquer hora e virar e meter a
faca no meu pescoço ela meu deus como é
que bota na câmera que eu sei mexer se
ela não me a gente você aqui abraçado
com estranha beleza samba não agora
consegui agora consegui botar na câmera
tira um olhar forte ba nesse botão
beleza agora você tirar fotos só
compensou demora para focar a beleza não
vai ler agora a pessoa já sabe que botou
na cama já aplicar essa mulher que bota
o lugar que tira foto já a beleza é o
que a gente já fica feliz em estar aqui
abraçando estranho ainda roupa estranha
então não só amiga que estabeleceu em
você arma o sorriso tem assim ó
te amo sorrisinho e na cabeça pode ficar
mais bonito assim é e fica no lugar aqui
o soccer desgraçado na versão de
tateando ela espera focar é só clicar na
tela não focar na hora espero ficar
sozinho eu sei que aqui é assim a gente
tira tira foto e estranha que aí vou
seguir a rota tirou o extremo do benfica
e quem não sai do lugar de novo a fé ela
da [ __ ] é a pessoa espera focar de novo
e todo mundo sabe que um sorriso na cara
por mais de dez segundo ele não sustenta
o cara começa sorriso assim ó vai passar
no segundo sorriso vai morrendo passa
dez segundo rita assim a pessoa que foi
um sonho com a foto se a pessoa passar
mais de 15 segundos com um sorriso na
cara dele pode ser branco ele fica
amarelo na hora a gente começa a perder
a paciência
glória você só tem logo agora beleza a
pessoa sabia photoshop na câmara o
senhor sabe que tem que focar a pessoa
não vai borrar mais só cai a desgraçada
esquece o cão do flash ligado tudo bem
normal isso é muito normal tudo o que é
normal o flash é normal só que tem flash
que parecem tiro cara faz a ponte com a
foto aqui ó atira fórum 23 veja
não satisfeita com toda essa raiva que
ela participasse ainda patinam
agora eu quero sair na foto alguém tira
pelo menos uma coisa boa acontece porque
aí o estranho que você está abraçando
que está se sentindo excluído da foto
que não é da família ele fala não eu
tiro é e sai daqui você meu graças a
deus você fica melhor mas é isso aí se
você tiver gostar desse vídeo você tiver
que no youtube é só você clicar em
gostei de você me ajuda demais toda lá
no facebook eu postei vídeo novo você
que curte lá no facebook essa postagem e
marcou amigos e os comentários que
também se sente assim na hora da foto é
de dourados mato grosso do sul e se
esquece que votar no dia 30 de outubro
eo dia 1º de novembro em campo grande
valeu em espelho